my history is your history
your history is my history
and our history is our story
we share the same place in time and
space in the world in today's society
and we
owe it to each other to know more about
our ancestors together
if we want to see the legacies of
slavery and colonialism in britain we
need look no further than the people
so my father left jamaica in 1958
he came here to live with his sister and
to find work
um he found that experience as you can
imagine
quite daunting um he often reminds me
of seeing smoke coming out of a chimney
in him thinking that
the house was on fire so he settled here
and
18 months later he sent for my mother
and my sister jen reed grew up in bath
the only black child at school where she
regularly encountered racism
i moved to bristol in 2012.
um you know i've always been very aware
of what bristol is and it being built on
the back of slavery
i remember an office that i had worked
in um
directly opposite was colston standing
proud over bristol the statue that jen
is referring to
was of edward colston a 17th century
bristol merchant
and slave trader he was a member of the
royal african company
between 1662 in 1731
the company transported 212
000 enslaved people across the atlantic
of whom 44 000 died on route
as well as the statue in the city centre
schools streets and many other buildings
in bristol were named after edward
colston
when he died he left a lot of his wealth
to charities in bristol and it's for
that reason why his name
was registered very largely on the city
but his
larger role in the trading of africans
for slavery and slave labor in the
caribbean
is something that is very important for
us to emphasize because it speaks to
a silence that often follows a lot of
these figures in history who were
involved in the slavery business
and how that silence is obscured by this
elevation of them
in these other roles that they performed
in their lives but on the 7th of june
2020 in the midst of global protests
against
racism sparked in part by the murder of
george floyd by an american policeman
protesters in bristol tore colston down
from his elevated status both literally
and figuratively jen reed and her
husband
alistair doggott were there attending
their first
ever political protest it was a sight to
behold it was almost like a carnival
atmosphere
i watched my husband drag edward colston
to the water and throw him in to the
water
it was just such an historic moment it
was an instinctive action on my behalf
as soon as i put my hands on him and we
started pushing him towards the water
then it was as simple as like i know how
to do that i can do that
let's do it jen's role in the protest
renewed her interest in tracing her
family tree
with the help of the legacies of slavery
database at ucl
she was finally able to find out more
about her family in jamaica
what really shook me to the core was
discovering that my great
great great great
grandmother was the first of my
ancestors to be enslaved
jen also discovered that the documents
relating to her five times great
grandmother
had listed her name as sylvia but that
wasn't her real name
like many enslaved people she'd been
given an english name by her enslaver
robbing her of her african identity i've
also discovered that
my grandmother five times removed
had a daughter and her daughter had a
daughter
and they were all kept together
by their enslaver by the name of
donald mclean it made me really angry
it made me want to research the mclean
clan
who are they where are they now what
riches do they have
a lot of those memories of slavery are
not memories that are just recorded and
registered in history books or that are
told
in classes these are memories that
people embody
they are memories that people carry from
generation to generation
for jen's husband alistair the black
lives matter protest
also triggered an interest in finding
out about his past
when he started looking into his family
history he found that he was related to
people with the surname colston
though there's no evidence that they
were connected to edward colston himself
i think it's uh it's a complex picture
when you try to unpick
the detail of everything about why race
is so important today and
and why people have to accept the truth
of
britain's involvement in the slave trade
i think
history can't be sectioned off and it's
this is your history this is my history
it's our history together
as well as personal connections to the
slave traders and the enslaved
in britain there are deep financial ones
when slavery in britain was abolished in
the 1830s
the government paid 20 million pounds to
slave owners in compensation
there was no compensation for the
formerly enslaved
the compensation of 20 million pounds
was really meant to be a form of
reparations
to slave owners for the loss of their
property in people
an extraordinary figure and that even as
we consider
today the 20 million pounds we should
also remember that it's a fraction of
the full extent of the wealth
earned by enslaved labor for great
britain in the entire period of british
slavery
a lot of that money ended up being
reinvested in banking in finance in the
commercial sector
but also in non-commercial activities in
the arts and in
museums and even in education and
philanthropic
associations and endeavors so there's
clearly a disconnect between the wealth
that slavery brought to britain
and the immense suffering inflicted on
those who were enslaved
in some cases it's only names that can
offer clues to the past
there are threads that are connected to
places and to place names why a
plantation in eastern jamaica
shares the name of a location in london
but there are also
threads that are connected to people why
someone in bridgetown barbados shares
the name of somebody in liverpool even
though they have never met they are tied
to that history
through the history of slavery and
colonialism and it is something that we
cannot ignore
as for jen although she knows the names
of her families in slaver
she still doesn't know her ancestor
sylvia's real name
or anything about her origins in africa
i want to know what tribe i belong to i
imagine
my tribe to be fearless because i am
fearless
and i am powerful and i imagine my
ancestors would be exactly the same
thanks for watching if you enjoyed that
be sure to check out these videos next
and if you haven't already hit the
subscribe button and click the bell to
get a notification
each time we upload a new video